hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen heute zu einem etwas
späteren video am abend weil ich einfach
von elf uhr abends bis 13 uhr mittags
geschlafen ab alter ich habe einfach 14
stunden geschlafen und so viel schlaf
nachgeholt den ich in den letzten tagen
immer verpasst habe und ich würde sagen
wir fangen jetzt an mit dem was ich euch
heute zeigen wollte und zwar hab ich mal
wieder in der welt von minecraft auf
youtube nachgeschaut was gibt es da neue
das kann man denn da zeigen wo der neu
gemacht sondern habe ich von jasper bmw
kennt wahrscheinlich seine mario möchte
ich auch mal vorgestellt habe um ein
grad ich kam einfach spielen mit
richtigen nationen ich bin groß erkennt
ihn wahrscheinlich und er macht richtig
coole maps in minecraft der link zu
seiner web und zum download und zum
video dazu und alles möglich ist und in
der beschreibung das heißt könnt ihr auf
jeden fall mal vorbeigucken und auf
jeden fall diese person unterstützen
weil er so viel ahnung von redstone und
allen möglichen hat und er hat ein
minecraft solitär gemacht an alle die
solitäre nicht kennen lernte scannen das
ist 100 spiel was ich schon damals bei
198 mit freunden nach der schule
gespielt habe ich hoffe ich kriege noch
auf die reihe und zwar hat er das ganze
in minecraft nachgebaut hier oben wieder
steht dann nur sowas wie das man auch
seinen channel gehen soll
wie das ganze erstmal funktioniert und
hier kann man rechts klicken damit das
ganze reset an dem er schon oder kommen
so bläschen und dann geht's los sondern
wieder neue karten und da ist ein
straßenschild als unsere button to get
stoned da kommen wir hinter uns das
ganze match zum angucken das kann am
ende machen obwohl ich davon mit
brettern nicht so ganz auf ihn können
wir trotzdem man nachher hinter gucken
und solitaire funktioniert einfach ihr
habt eine hohe karte wie beispielsweise
diese 10 in rot also dieses herz karo
kreuz und pique müsst ihr nicht beachten
dass es total dummen eigentlich soll das
braucht man nicht man braucht nur
schwarz und rot muss man sich merken auf
eine rote karte muss immer eine kleine
schwarze karte und auf eine schwarz
karte muss immer eine kleine rote karte
wir haben hier schon einen schneeball in
der hand und die reihenfolge ist es 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10
bube dame könig also es ist die kleinste
karte und bekommt jetzt einfach mal auf
diese zehn da den schnee bald darauf
werfen ob ich hab sogar getroffen und
jetzt ist ja 19 buben das heißt wir
können die zehn jetzt darauf setzen
details haben die schmerzmedizin jetzt
darauf gesetzt und wir können jetzt
weitermachen wir haben beispielsweise
hier eine 3 eine schwarze 3 die setzen
wir jetzt mal aufgibt 4
dann haben wir hier diesen ganzen stapel
da nehmen wir aber jetzt habe ich in die
drei ich vollidiot setzte wieder darauf
ich muss die vier treffen irgendwie soll
nämlich dass beides 4 und 3 und können
das ganze jetzt auf diese fünf darauf
setzen jetzt haben wir fünf vier drei
sie schon mal ein toller start finde ich
eigentlich gerade da nehmen wir die zwei
und können die hier auf die drei
draufsetzen
das ist schon mal richtig gut jetzt
werden wir einfach mal dahin damit ihr
ich treffe mal wieder nicht ich vor
video jetzt habe ich einfach mal auf die
anderen drei karten da links mal schnee
mal drauf geworfen und die werden jetzt
quasi wieder um gedeckt und wir können
jetzt mal schauen was haben wir denn
jetzt für sachen die wir da theoretisch
verbinden können wir natürlich erst mal
okay wir haben das hier die fünf kann
ich nirgendwo drauf setzen die sieben
auf die acht geht nicht als die gleiche
farbe ist der geht auf kleinsten eine
schwarze zwei auch nicht weil wir zwei
haben also alle höher und das hier
dafür bräuchte ich dafür braucht es
allerdings wenn das ganze nicht
funktioniert können wir einfach mal hier
oben eine gerade drauf werfen und wir
sehen jetzt hier sport eine neue karte
wir können diese sieben jetzt einfach
mal nehmen da auf die acht
beispielsweise draufpacken
das ganze bringt es aber auch nicht viel
weiter und wir sagen weil einfach kommen
wenn jemand mal hier nicht die 10
ich will dich denken nicht die zähne ich
will den 1
genau das und dass ich meine wir können
das jetzt können wir nicht aber wir
können nicht darauf setzen wofür war
dennoch mal das war das für einzelne
karten ich bin mir gar nicht sicher wo
für diese einzelnen teile da waren was
bringt das nochmal das ist nicht das
einzige was ich mich auch gefragt habe
wo ich mir das ganze angeschaut hab ich
bin nicht mehr so affen mit solitaire
aber was bringt diese klubs einfach
mikrofon geschlagen was bringt diese
sachen ich weiß dass das ganze hier
da kann ich in us drauflegen meine ich
also die ganze karte aber wir machen
einfach weiter da oben
ich meine ich spieler spiel nicht gut
ich möchte euch quasi einfach nur zeigen
das ist jetzt auch nicht so toll da
unten die die dame
daneben bringt uns auch nicht viel und
nachher beim echten solitär ist es quasi
so wenn das ganze hier mehr oder weniger
aufgebraucht ist also nur eine bestimmte
anzahl an karten und die sind alle
darüber dann werden die karten wieder
gemischt und dahin gepackt oder ich weiß
nicht ob sie gemischt werden das kann
man ja nicht beurteilen weil seinem
computer der macht jetzt nicht im video
tack tack tack akademisch aber es ist
halt so dass man dann punkte abgezogen
bekommt wenn man hat die ganzen karten
aufgebracht hat google damit könig passt
auch nicht zusammen bringt jetzt also
auch erst mal nichts bube dame da ist
eine dame diese dame ist jetzt die frage
kann ich die gang setzen ich meine nicht
nur ein kann ich nicht kann ich denn die
dame dahin setzen geht auch nicht anders
ist ein bisschen traurig weil ich
brauch' ich brauche meine karte ich
glaube ich kann da wirklich nur eines
einzelnen sätzen aber ich bin mir echt
nicht sicher da es nur sechs die können
mich erst mal gebrauchen das heißt wir
nehmen es die sechst- und platzieren die
da drauf dann haben wir da schon mal die
6 das bräuchten wir eine schwarze 5 oder
endlich mal was über das mainz nebel so
dass die schwarze acht das aber auch
blöd oder kann ich nicht theoretisch
kann ich nicht so was habe ich denn
jetzt hab ich die acht genommen
das ist ein bisschen ich weiß nicht wie
kriege ich diese acht dahinter das ist
so eine sache die mich so ein bisschen
stört gerade aber wahrscheinlich aber
ist die fünf wahrscheinlichkeit das noch
gar nicht richtig ich möchte euch ja
eigentlich auch nur zeigen was ist
mittlerweile gibt und dass ihr diese
besser unterstützt das klappt aber ich
tat gut jetzt können die vier da drauf
packen brauchen wir noch eine rote 3
eine schwarze 3 da ist die sexy 6 bringt
uns gerade nichts wir brauchen einfach
mal ein ass ich habe ja noch gar kein
ass irgendwie bekommen die zwei bringen
uns gerade auch nichts die 9
da muss die neue hinter dahinter aber
halten doch ich kann die neuen ja dahin
setzen
ok und jetzt jetzt kommt der große zug
nehmen wir diese nein in denen ein wenig
höher wir nehmen das alles platzieren es
daran haben wir hier schon mal immens
viel
jetzt brauchen wir noch die drei wir
können ja theoretisch mal hier ist mit
der drei wegnehmen das kann man nämlich
auch machen platzieren dass da unten
dran und das einzige was wir jetzt
brauchen ist ein schwarzes
und dame und könig bube dame könig genau
da ist die fünf die bringt uns nicht
sonderlich viel wir gehen aber einfach
mal weiter
da ist das schwarze asta schwarzers
nehme jetzt mal mit nachbar unten
komplett schwarzes form und jetzt ist
halt nur die sache wie kriege ich diesen
ganzen schwachsinn wie kann ich denn
jetzt dahin oder sogar nicht den er
nicht irgendwie verteilen
das ist nämlich das was mich so ein
bisschen stört funktioniert das ganze
einfach nicht oder geht es im elften
spiel aber hier nicht das ist halt so
eine sache die ich gern mal wissen würde
wenn ihr das ist dann einfach in die
kommentare damit ihr wisst wie es läuft
ich mich wieder runter sehen was hier
hinter für karten sind ich glaube das
sind alles nur karten dahinter die ich
wirklich brauche die neuen bringt uns
auch sonderlich wenig aber ich denke mal
ich habe euch das ganze ganz gut gezeigt
ich möchte mal ungern sagen ich hab ich
das ganze gut gezeigt weil viele mal
nach rhede sind irgendwie unter bringt
gar nichts was du laberst und jetzt sind
wir mal dass und packen das sich auf die
zwei drauf
zwei unterschiedliche farben und kleiner
denn je das patent zwei unterschiedliche
farben aber kleiner den e
ja diese diesen bube dame könig diese
droht dame und den den könig hätten wir
ganz gut gebrauchen können allerdings
ich bin mir nicht sicher was ist denn
ich möchte den könig jetzt irgendwie mal
hierhin kriegen keinen sinn jetzt geht s
einfach jetzt geht's einfach wie so geht
das denn
also das frage ich mich wieso gibt es
das jetzt geht das vielleicht mit diesen
sachen mit diesem besonderen karten nee
wieso dienstgrad mit dem könig ich
verstehe es nicht ich bin echt über
frage dass es nachts auch ich freue mich
dass wenn du sechs vielleicht die acht
dahin setzen
wie kann ich auch nicht mal eine freude
wenn ihr es wisst wenn ihr ahnung von
solitaire absehbare ich möchte euch das
ganze nur gezeigt haben diese 65 jetzt
kenne die fünf sätzen ich wollte euch
nur gezeigt haben wenn es euch gefallen
hat und eventuell mehr game app
vorstellungen wollt ich hab das emmental
mit der map und der und blablabla dann
zeigt es mit einer bewertung schreibt
venter in die kommentare wenn ihr tipps
habt bezüglich solitär oder was eure
highscores oder was weiß ich
ach so wir wollten uns ja noch das
rennen schnell anschauen so jetzt nehme
ich das ganze hier ich geh mal kurz in
den game mode
können wir auch mal ein bisschen herum
fliegen hier seht ihr wie das ganze
aufgebaute score players okay das ist
jetzt das mit risiken genau das ist das
und das also das einzige was ich quasi
weiß ist wo wir schon dass wir denen die
normale weg begeben wenn man hier mal
rum fliegt ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
man das sieht dass jedes land sind sieht
man dass hier irgendwie sieht man dass
sie angenehm wie hier sind ihr müsst
euch forschen hier sind überall slams
hinter den karten und wenn man quasi
drauf drückt wenn man hier jetzt
irgendwie wenn ich da draufdrücken
absichtlich kaputt gemacht nicht als du
hier drauf druck unter sondern irgendwie
neue karten oder irgendwie so dann geht
quasi hier immer sonst leimbeck geht
hier in seiner reihe und der unterste
islam wird dann wieder da integriert und
lassen quasi die katen reihenfolge nach
und nach wenn ihr das ganze genauer
sehen wollt also dass sich schüler die
hier oben stehen
wenn das ganze genauer sehen wollt ihr
seht ihr den kanal youtube programmchef
jasper de entzwei und da ist das ganze
noch mal erklärt wie ihr das ganze
gemacht hat und ein kleines
vorstellungsvideo was auch sehr witzig
zusammen geschnitten ist ich würde sagen
mir gefällt das ganze das war's mit der
map vorstellungen und wir sehen uns dann
irgendein gerät video wieder übrigens
ich ziehe ja um nach hamburg und ich
habe derzeit auch nur noch einen pc hier
ich hab ja sonst noch einen zweiten
bildschirm
den habe ich allerdings schon in hamburg
dann wäre ja viele sachen stehen
gebracht habe und deswegen habe ich
jetzt auch die city openbroadcast da
mein fels kein programm minecraft und
outdoor polnischen also fünf programme
auf einem bildschirm anstands auf zwei
wie sich das verändert ich liebe diese
neue fans kann dies killer und wir also
nur dass ihr da nicht denkt das dann
irgendwie wenn man irgendwas nicht
klappt von atomen spur oder so
entschuldigt mich ich habe jetzt alle
fünf fenster hier irgendwie
nebeneinander und ich hoffe ich das
irgendwie hin aber gut